[Music]
yesterday GCP announced a very exciting
new product called cloud run it's a
service that allows you to convert any
back-end code written in any programming
language with any dependencies into a
service function this means you can
deploy fully managed micro services that
will scale automatically while only
paying for the actual resources that you
use in today's video I'll show you how
to take a server-side rendered
JavaScript application containerize it
with docker deploy to cloud run and then
hook it up to firebase hosting if you're
new here like and subscribe and you can
grab the full walkthrough from buyer
ship IO I'm really excited about cloud
run because it's the service I've been
wishing for ever since I started working
with service functions the single
biggest problem with server list has
always been the limitation of the
runtime most cloud providers only offer
a few different programming languages
and if you need any special dependencies
in your runtime then you're basically
out of luck your only real option at
that point is to provision a virtual
machine or use something like App Engine
to deploy your code and those resources
are always online which means you're
always paying for them and you also have
to worry about scaling them up and down
cloud run is basically the best of both
worlds and really the future of cloud
computing in general in my opinion all
you have to do as a developer is write
your code and then wrap it in a docker
image the one thing to keep in mind
though is that your code needs to be
stateless in other words you can't be
saving permanent files to the file
system or be running a sequel database
and expect to have access to that data
later that shouldn't be a problem
because you should be building stateless
applications anyway while using things
like cloud storage fires store or cloud
sequel to manage your persistent data
now let's take a look at a few things
that you might want to start using cloud
run for the first thing is server-side
rendering JavaScript applications I'm
going to show you how to do this with
Knux j/s and view but the same
principles apply to angular Universal or
next j/s with react
you could also hypothetically use it to
build a more traditional web application
like say WordPress or Ruby on Rails as
long as you keep the database outside of
the container and I find this one really
interesting because that means you could
have a wordpress site hosted on firebase
hosting and another use case for cloud
run would just be to create restful api
soar even graph QL api's and feel free
to do it in whatever programming
language you want now let's go ahead and
take a look at a full example from start
to finish we're going to take this
knucks j/s app which is just a view app
that server-side rendered with express
j/s will create a docker image for it
and deploy it as a micro service to
cloud run and as a final touch I'll show
you how to integrate it with firebase
hosting to follow along with this lesson
you'll need to have docker installed on
your local system as well as the Google
Cloud SDK first we need to create an app
or a micro service that we can deploy
I'll be using knucks j/s for this demo
and the reason I chose next is because
it's really easy to get started with
server-side rendering from the
command-line we ran npx create knucks
tap and then it will give us a handful
of options that we can run through
mostly we'll just select the defaults
here the only important thing is to
select Universal as the rendering mode
from there we can open it up in vs code
and then run npm run dev to serve the
app locally that's just running an
Express j/s server with node and you
should see something that looks like
this in the browser on localhost 3000
I'm not going to spend any time changing
the underlying nuts code it's already
ready to go we just need to docker eyes
it I'm not going to get into the
fundamentals of docker in this video but
you can think of an image as an
executable of your application we create
this image by defining a docker file and
in that file we define a series of steps
required to build the actual virtual
machine or container that runs our code
so even if you've never used docker
before it's actually very intuitive and
easy to write a docker file because
you're basically just doing the same
things that you would normally do from
the command line to run your app go
ahead and create a docker file in the
root of the application and the first
step in any docker file is to define the
base image this is usually just a
minimal operating system like a Linux
distro or in our case since we're
building a node app we'll use the node
10 image which is just a Linux distro
with node version 10 installed you can
think of the steps in a docker file
similar to these steps that you would
run from the command line for cloud run
we're going to set the working directory
as user source app that's kind of like
seeding into a directory and then we'll
set an environment variable called port
this environment variable is very
important in this case because cloud
runs going to be looking for this port
and expose it so you can actually
interact with the service after it's
deployed and we'll also define a host
environment variable because next we'll
be looking for the host and the port to
determine how to serve the app the next
thing we'll do is copy the package JSON
files in the working directory and then
we'll run NPM install only for our
production dependencies from there we'll
copy all the source code from our local
project to the working directory then
we'll run NPM build to build the
production next app and then npm start
which is the command that actually
starts the service in this container
so that's our entire dockerfile now that
we have that complete we want to build
the image itself we can run docker build
and then point to the directory that
contains the docker file that's going to
build out the image in a series of steps
or layers and now docker knows how to
reproduce our code so it can scale to an
infinite number of containers after
that's done you'll notice that gives us
an image ID down here at the bottom you
can use that ID to run the container
locally which is generally a good idea
just to make sure everything is working
before you deploy it you can do that
with docker run and then you should see
the same next app being served on
localhost 8080 now that we know that
everything is working properly we need
to tag this image and then upload it to
the Container registry on GCP we can do
that by first running docker tag
followed by the image ID and then
followed by GC r io slash your project
ID slash whatever you want to call this
service that associates the image with
this URL then you can run docker push to
actually upload it to that URL that's
going to take a few minutes but when
it's finished you can go to the GCP
console and see it in the container
registry and just a side note you can
use cloud build to entirely automate
this process if you don't want to do it
manually like I just showed you and I
made a video all about that a few weeks
ago the next step is to take this image
and deploy it as a micro service with
cloud run head over to the container
registry on GC P and verify that the
image that you just uploaded is
available there from there head over to
cloud run and we'll create a new service
by clicking on the create service button
that will give us the option to select a
container image URL which we can do for
our knucks server and just give it a
name and a location and then make sure
to check the button for allow
unauthenticated invocations
this is a public app so we want anybody
to be able to access the service it'll
take a few minutes to finish but when
it's done you should be able to see the
logs coming from the container and then
you'll see a URL that we can use to
access the service over HTTP and if we
open it in a browser we should see the
same exact next app that we were working
with locally now at this point we could
map the service domain to our own custom
domain and that can be done directly
through the cloud run console but cloud
run is also integrated with firebase so
we can actually map this service to our
firebase hosting account at this point
I'm assuming you have the firebase
command line tools installed then run
firebase in it hosting from inside of
the next app you can select all the
default options then choose no when
asked if it's a single page application
firebase will automatically create a
public directory you want to go ahead
and keep that directory
but delete the index.html that's inside
it firebase hosting will get a higher
priority to this index.html file than it
will to rewrites and what we're actually
doing here is rewriting all of our
traffic to that micro service endpoint
we do that by going into the firebase
JSON file add a rewrites array and then
define an object that has a property of
source which points to star star which
will just capture all the routes in this
app and then a second property called
run which will point to the service ID
or the service name that we defined and
cloud run from there we just need to run
firebase deploy only hosting and now we
have a next app deployed to firebase
hosting with full server-side rendering
and like I mentioned earlier you can do
the same thing with angular universal or
react next or whatever you want but more
importantly cloud run basically removes
all the limitations that we used to face
when building serverless apps I'm gonna
go ahead and wrap things up there but
expect more cloud run videos in the
future because it opens the door to all
kinds of interesting possibilities if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO to get access to
even more content thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon
[Music]